quand vous vous installez comme en
voiture clic je mets ma ceinture de
sécurité ces jeunes du lycée agricole
d'emboise passent un test de conduite de
tracteur qure CRS prodigu les conseils
au programme une manœuvre en marche
arrière l'installation en bonne et
duuformme et avec la ceinture une mise
en situation réelle de conduite sur la
voie publique donc à César retenez bien
j'ai le droit à un seul outil
atteler et la seconde chose j'ai le
droit à 2,50 de large maximum 18 m de
long après la pratique la théorie ici à
la Maison Familiale Rurale de sorign les
futurs paysagiste passent aussi un code
spécifique ce qui est paradoxal par
rapport à il y a 40 ans c'est que le
nombre de matériel qui évolue sur la
route ont considérablement augmenté
avant les exploitations
étaient très proches et contigu je
dirais donc on avait pas besoin de trop
trop sortir sur la haau publique étant
donné que maintenant il y a moins
d'exploitation et du fait de la
dissémination des exploitations donc les
gens se transportent sur la route se
projettent sur la route depuis 40 ans
que l'opération 10 de conduite rurale
existe on est passé de 1300 accidents de
la route impliquant des engins agricoles
à moins de 300 une bonne nouvelle sauf
que 9 accidents sur 10 se produisent sur
l'exploitation mais comme la France
n'est plus le pays agricole qu'il était
les trajets sur la voie publique sont de
plus en plus fréquents on a une
cohabitation sur les routes des péis
urbains qui vont travailler en ville et
des engins agricoles qui circulent
semaine chaque année 100000 accidents du
travail sont recensés dans les
entreprises agricoles et les policiers
de lancer un appel comme un light motive
au volant d'un tracteur ce n'est pas le
patron de l'exploitation qui est
responsable en cas d'accident c'est bien
le conducteur